es el juicio más grande en la historia
moderna de francia
reflejando la naturaleza sin precedente
de los crímenes este viernes los
abogados de sala abdeslam han presentado
sus argumentos finales su cliente
enfrenta la pena máxima que existe en el
código penal francés esto por tomar
parte en los ataques terroristas el 13
de noviembre de 2015 después de seis
meses de silencio abdeslam se abrió ante
la corte compartiendo su versión de los
eventos admitió que su misión fue dejar
a los atacantes suicidas en las afueras
del estado de france y luego cometer el
mismo un ataque fui a un café en el
distrito 18 ordené una bebida mire a la
gente a mi alrededor y pensé no voy a
hacer esto y no lo hice no por miedo
sino por mi humanidad al invocar su
propia humanidad para supuestamente
justificar la decisión consciente de no
matar a otros el acusado impactó a las
víctimas
está disfrutando el pequeño poder que
tiene creo que quiere sacar provecho de
la situación
en abril el último día que habló en el
estrado sala abdeslam presentó sus
disculpas a las víctimas ahora los
jueces deben determinar la sinceridad de
sus palabras y tomar en cuenta los
centenares de víctimas expertos y
testigos que han testificado durante
nueve meses el veredicto se anunciará el
próximo miércoles